à la situation à kiev qui est l'une des
villes symboles
les yeux ont ils sont resté rivé sur sur
la capitale ukrainienne dès le début de
cette crise nous envoyés spéciaux 1
depuis le début de cette guerre évolué
sur le sur le terrain et je me trouve au
côté de james andré bonjour james de
retour de terrain joue juste vous avez
passé deux semaines dans qu'il y avait
ça et sa banlieue on a vu tout à l'heure
cette libération symbolique en tout est
annoncé comme tel par le président
volume me raser lenski dire pin's que
vous vous avez pu constater à la fin de
votre mission c'est que la population
restée sur place ils sont encore deux
millions tout de même commence peu à peu
à tenter de reprendre le cours de leur
vie oui absolument alors l'ambiance à
kiev c'est quelque chose d'assez
particulière c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il ya la guerre juste à
côté irp insee juste à côté c'est 15
kilomètres de kiev où faisait le point
là bas alors effectivement pendant qu'on
a été là bas on nous a dit que les
russes avaient avancé ensuite on nous a
dit qu'ils avaient des opérations
spéciales de la part des ukrainiens pour
reprendre la ville et à kiev en réalité
tout le monde a les yeux rivés sur here
pin sur brovary qui est l'autre front
sur le nord-est est évidemment tout le
monde retient son souffle avec donc
fréquemment évidemment les sirènes qui
démarre et puis ces frappes sporadiques
qu'on a pu voir ni sur les immeubles sur
place qui ont été détruits alors parfois
c'était un appartement parfois c'est
tout l'immeuble qui était frappée au
pied qui était qui était largement
détruit des gens qui sont obligés de
quitter mais ça reste si vous voulez une
situation on a des frappes sporadiques
donc il ya une pression tout le monde
retient son souffle mais c'est vrai
qu'on est arrivé si vous voulez on a vu
un changement dans la ville c'est à dire
quand on est arrivé on était dans une
ville fantôme tout était fermé tout
était à l'arrêt total les magasins
étaient tous
fermé par exemple c'était difficile de
trouver si on partait pour tourner pour
une journée difficile de trouver de quoi
déjeuner en fait parce que les
restaurants sont fermés il ya aucun peut
pas acheter un sandwich et enfin on
mangeait dans la voiture ce qu'on avait
sur nous quoi parce qu'il n'y avait rien
d'autre et puis progressivement on a vu
les choses seraient ouvrir alors c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a vu dans un
premier temps quand la guerre a éclaté
tout le monde c'est enterrer les gens
qui t'aiment sidération film l'état de
sidération une grosse partie de la femme
déjà enfuis et nous ce qu'on a vu c'est
avec l'équipe avec johnattan walsh et
david ormezzano c'est un petit retour à
la vie c'est à dire les magasins qui
finalement se réapprovisionnent qui
rouvre une directrice de supermarché qui
nous dit m'écouter non mon métier c'est
de nourrir les gens si je ne travaille
pas les gens n'ont rien à manger donc
qui dit non c'est mon rôle de rester là
je ne fuis pas je n'enterre pas je tiens
mon magasin on a eu également un jour on
est allé à la gare faire un sujet avec
la police ils nous ont expliqué que le
petit kiosque à café au revers c'est
intéressant j'ai demandé à la dame gym
vous aver quand elle m'a dit on a ouvert
aujourd'hui jeudi mais vous n'avez pas
peur m'a dit écoutez qu'on soit ici ou
chez nous de toute façon risque de se
prendre un truc sur la tête donc autant
ouvrir le café servir le café et
permettre aux gens prendre un café je
peux vous dire que j'en étais content
prendre leur café donc on a vu j'allais
dire à un début de vie qui repart à kiev
et un début de reprise des gens qui sont
revenus finalement dans leur ville et on
assiste maintenant c'est ce qu'on a vu
dans des reportages mais un retour de la
population et à côté de cela une très
grande solidarité c'est ce qui a émergé
dès le début de ce conflit entre
ukrainiens quelles que soient les les
statuts les origines aussi et cette
détermination cette volonté qui s'est
imposé finalement quasi immédiatement un
grand nombre d'ukrainiens de prendre les
armes de rester et défendre le pays vous
vous avez approché la résistance est à
l'ukrainienne vous avez nourri nos
antennes avec des reportages c'est ce
que vous avez retenu un finalement de
ces deux semaines de mission oui tout à
fait alors d'abord une très grande
détermination à défendre l'ukraine alors
avec des choses intéressantes par
exemple le fait que les gens se sont mis
pour certains parce que beaucoup de gens
sont de langue maternelle russes et les
deux lans cohabitaient beaucoup en
ukraine on voit beaucoup de gens qui
font l'effort de parler ukrainien alors
ça c'est quelque chose qui a vraiment
démarré avec la guerre notamment
rencontré un entrepreneur en c2 à lui
que je pense lui parler plutôt en russe
ella e-bay s'est mis à parler
exclusivement ukrainien même s'il a un
accent et qu'il accroche de temps en
disant non je veux parler la langue de
mon pays et lui par exemple ils
fabriquaient de la peinture c'était dans
un reportage et il s'est lancé dans la
fabrication de gilets pare balles et de
la distribution de médicaments de la
même manière on a rencontré des gens qui
prenaient les armes qui décide de signer
un contrat avec la résistance
territoriale ukrainienne ce qui veut
quand même dire qu'ils cessent d'être
des civils faut le savoir c'est que les
gens qui s'enrôlent dans ces forces là
cesse d'être civile deviennent des
combattants et des lords deviennent des
cibles légitimes pour l'armée russe donc
c'est pas rien alors leur a posé la
question et ils nous disent mais écouter
de toute façon l'armée russe cible tout
le monde donc autant défendre le pays et
se battre donc ils font ils prennent
cette décision qui est quand même
importante donc il s'enrôle pour trois
ans pour le pour l'info il ressort pour
trois ans ou jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
mais en tout cas leur objectif c'est
vraiment de défendre le pays donc on
voit une très belle solidarité aussi
bien sur le plan civil avec des gens qui
vont nourrir les gens qui sont dans la
difficulté les loger préparer des sous
sols pour l'accuser accueillir quand ils
s'excluent litres dire pineau d'autres
zones et dans le même temps des gens qui
sont avocats garagiste ce qu'on veut
qu'ils prennent les armes et qui décide
d'aller au front tout le monde se met à
aider même à son bras son petit niveau
merci beaucoup james pour ce retour de
terrain vous trouvera dans la suite de
paris